when it comes to horror a satisfying
ending could be particularly challenging
be it because of a cheap jump scare
nonsensical finale or even mediocre
attempts of viral marketing these horror
flicks all left audiences feeling
disappointed that is sent as an
excellent horror film about a group of
friends who get lost during a caving
expedition well the premise is
relatively simple the film stands out
thanks to its claustrophobic and
hopeless approach mixed in with
thoughtful character dynamics and
exchanges additionally as it goes on the
film turns into a suspenseful
action-packed experience when it becomes
apparent that bloodthirsty cave crawlers
are hunting the group for the
character's story creepy atmosphere and
even lighting her or masterfully
executed the film suffers from a less
than stellar conclusion as least in the
American release you see that a sense
has two separate endings but the
audiences in the UK seeing a whole
different one or at least an extended
one in the American cuts the main
character Sarah seemingly escapes from
the cave and drives off she pulls over
to vomit up the window and the she leans
back into her seat there's a jump scare
involving Juno one of the deceased women
this is where the version ends but it
isn't the descents true clothes in the
UK cuts the jump scare wakes Sarah who
never actually escaped from the cave as
the cave crawlers presumably closing
around her she envisions a birthday
scene with the deceased daughter the
film cuts to black hinting at her death
apparently it was just too dark for
American audiences directed by M night
Shyamalan happening as a thriller about
a group of survivors trying to make it
through an apocalyptic disaster however
like many of Shyamalan films it suffers
from a strange twist and left viewers
both confused and disappointed in
Central Park people begin to kill
themselves on mass causing a panic about
a bioterrorist attack as the death
spread across large swathes of the
United States early it's more a high
school science teacher travels with his
wife and his best friend eventually they
figure out that the deaths are being
caused by plants releasing a chemical
into the air that targets humans hello
my name is Elliot
is going to talk in a very positive
manner ultimately though the effects of
the plans pass without killing everyone
at the end of the film it has revealed
that the plants only affected the
northeastern United States and that's
another set of deaths has begun in Paris
what makes a happening less than stellar
and so we eternal the film takes after
it has revealed that the plants are
killing people as it turns out the
plants randomly decide not to kill the
protagonist there isn't a specific
reason why he is spared which makes a
story like any real meaning or
consequence days after Isabella Rossi's
mother killed two priests in an urn at
jurgen exorcism her father died as well
ever since the incidents isabella has
wanted to learn more about the exorcism
to fully grasp the religious ritual she
travels to Rome to visit the Vatican
school for exorcism and to accompany two
priests as they perform a series of
unsanctioned rituals however things get
dicey when the demons started Sagi
Isabella and the priests devil inside
was created on a shoestring budget of
just 1 million dollars and it definitely
feels unpolished as a result the film
was presented in a found-footage
mockumentary style that purports to show
real exorcisms everything about the
demonic possession looks fake except for
one scene featuring a professional
contortionist though the film is
imperfect his faults could probably be
forgiven if not for the terrible ending
as the story comes to a halt there is a
car crash and then everything just cuts
to black a car then flashes on the
screen imploring viewers to visit a web
site to help continue the investigation
into this case in the end the film need
that ties up things need leave nor
leaves you with intriguing questions to
ponder instead it prompts a viewer to
continue the storyline posing as a work
of nonfiction this marketing approach
did not go over well among audiences as
a results the devil insiders become
infamous and horror circles for his
uniquely terrible ending in sinister
Alison Oswalt moves into a new home with
his wife and two children unknown to his
wife their new home was once a crime
scene where a family was brutally killed
in the backyard being a true crime
writer Edison begins investigating the
case as an inspiration for his upcoming
book as Alison digs deeper and deeper he
learns that there is something more
sinister at first and that the crime is
linked to a supernatural creature
spooked by the eerie occurrences
surrounding the murders Alison
as family back to their previous home
seemingly in the clear he decides to put
the case behind him and to move on with
his life but after a deputy calls to
warn him about his family being in
danger Ellison is killed by his
possessed daughter it was then taken by
the demonic being bug all the ending
feels cheesy and uninspired and there
isn't much build-up to the conclusion so
it comes across as rushed even more
insult in this pacing is the final shot
like so many other cheaply done horror
flicks the end features a jump scare of
peggle to try and provoke a last-minute
thrill unfriended follows Blair a
teenager hanging out with her friends
over video chats it isn't long before
they notice a stranger going by Billie 2
to 7 entering their chats confused the
group tries to uncover the anonymous
person's identity in response to Billie
two to seven threatens to expose
privates information about each of them
eventually Blair discovers the stranger
is actually the ghost of Laura bonds a
high school student who killed herself
after an embarrassing viral video was
uploaded online the film finds Blair
interacting with the rest of the cast
over instant message and video chats as
each of them is driven to kill
themselves one by one eventually she's
the only one left alive to face Laura's
ghost in the end that Laura reveals to
all of Blair's Facebook friends that
Blair was the one who uploaded the video
that caused Laura to kill herself how
exactly does the film end well if we
look at how every other character died
the best assumption would be that Blair
would also die by her own hand however
the film deviates from this pattern by
having the ghost of Laura attack Blair
from behind her laptop for a last-minute
jump scare not only is it a cheap move
derivative of so many other horror
movies it breaks unfriended otherwise
clever gimmick of taking place entirely
on a computer screen the events of mama
kick off at the beginning of the 2008
financial crisis that's when jeffrey
desange kills us coworkers and his wife
then takes his two daughters Victoria
and Lily out of the house and drives
them down an icy mountain road driving
too fast he goes over a cliff and the
free then Trek to an abandoned cabin
where he is killed by a paranormal
creature five years later the girls are
rescued and sent to live with their
fathers when brother Luke and his
girlfriend Annabelle now feral and
suffering from years of isolation the
girls are difficult to care for and
refer to someone called mama though mama
is initially brushed off as a coping
mechanism created by the girls it
quickly becomes apparent that mama is
very real more chilling is that she
intends to keep the girls or to herself
and a
Lucan front mama who has taken the girls
to a cliff where she had killed herself
and her infant child a century prior in
a hilarious West Victoria simply tells
mama she doesn't want to go with her
[Music]
shockingly the evil spirit Kylie hits a
request in the end mama takes a willing
Lilly and the movie ends it seems like
the children could have just told mama
to go away and that would have been the
end of it
additionally the ending scene utilizes a
prominent blue filter and unconvincing
CGI that helps the showdown that only
feel terrible that look terrible as well
in this French slasher to friends Marie
and Alex find themselves hunted by a
vicious serial killer who breaks into
Alex's family home in the middle of the
night
he kills off Alex's family one by one
and eventually captures Alex forcing
Marita safer though high-tension may
seem on the surface like nothing more
than an average slasher what really
makes it stand out as his outlandish
twist ending by the end of the film we
learned of a big burly killer that has
been pursuing Marie and Alex rather film
was actually a personality invented by
Marie so in actuality Marie was a killer
the entire time despite this being
impossible based on what the film had
shown previously when Marie is revealed
to be the actual killer the entire logic
of the film crumbles apart resulting in
massive plot holes that are impossible
to ignore upon a second viewing well the
premise could have worked if executed
with the more careful focus on
perspective the final product has an end
that feels lazily tacked on to create a
cheap twist under the guise of something
psychologically sophisticated M night
Shyamalan the village is a sort of
period piece about a rural town
surrounded by dangerous creatures a film
hints at the unstable peace between the
village and the red-robed dwellers in
the woods will soon come to an end when
the group of young people must venture
into the trees despite the protruding
spikes the long claws and the coat
escalade inhuman crunch that these
creatures make it is later revealed that
these creatures are really just
villagers trying to scare the young
residents into never leaving the village
what it may seem like a silly twist the
real twist is much harder to swallow
after a blind girl manages to make it
through the woods she encounters a man
who can help her find medicines needed
to aid the village unbeknownst to her
he's actually a park ranger who spotted
her while driving his car it's revealed
the village actually exists in the
modern day a children have been exclu
from all forms of modern life simply
because the adults wanted to get away
from the troubles of the world the
purpose was out of hope something good
adapted from the 1998 Japanese horror
film of the same name
2002 sir ring saw a fair amount of
success among American filmmakers the
haunting Samara and a curse VHS tape
certainly left an impression among
audiences and even resulted in a sequel
in 2005 there were performed poorly
compared to its predecessor after the
Rings so the series seemingly
disappeared with no plans for another
film however in 2017 rings was released
bringing Samara back to the center stage
similar to the ring Rings follows a girl
named Julia who's exposed to a cursed
video that will result in her death
unless she figures out how to lift the
curse while the entirety of the film is
contrived and filled with questionable
cinematic and narrative choices the
ending is absolutely baffling by the end
of rings Julia is seemingly in the clear
after dispelling the evil spirits
however in typical horror fashion not
everything is as it seems
Julia begins to suffer from strange
occurrences she coughs up hair and the
ultimately culminates in Samarra sending
a digital copy of the cursed video to
everyone on Julia's contact list in the
end of the cursed video goes viral
despite looking like spam that most
people would ignore in a matter of
minutes any progress made by julia is
unraveled and the video spreads to the
rest of the world check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]